just days before the new Supreme Court
termed Justice Stephen Breyer sharing
his concern about the possibility of
putting cameras inside the court we
spoke to the 79 year old Associate
Justice last night in Connecticut Breyer
said cameras could change the behavior
of lawyers and the justices during oral
arguments you all think that you're
immune from changing your behavior
because the press is always there after
all they're always in the room they hear
the oral argument they're right in front
of us and you I think I say what I think
unfortunately I sometimes say things
little idiotic but I'll get over it and
and but wait till you see yourself on
television the first time with a picture
and they're saying something you're
saying those words and it's quite clear
to you at the time you meant the
opposite but what they're doing is
they're putting it in such a way that in
context it looks as if you're doing
something really unfortunate wait'll you
see that once you see it you will watch
what you say much more carefully and I
don't want to watch what I say I want to
say what I think there and find out the
Breyer said he does think cameras will
eventually be allowed inside the court
I'm familiar with this argument but I
have to tell you it really got me
thinking in a different way
last night he wants to judge a case by
what he sees excuse me by what he reads
not what he sees and he wants people to
see the courts decisions that way to
think about that it might allow for a
more objective deliberate reading of the
law so that you're not judging someone
by what they look like and I do think
cameras change the change the tone
change your behavior if you're not used
to being on TV all that the other side
of that argument is at some point you
get used to it and it doesn't have that
effect
well it's just like cinema verite
following people around at some point
they forget they can't forget the
cameras are there